wild new rumors plaguing scandival hey
Ariana what do you think about the rumor
the pregnancy rumor well Ariana maddox's
driver shut the door on that one a
source tells E.T Raquel is not pregnant
as for whether the Vanderpump Rules star
actually moved out of the home she
bought with Tom I'm moving up not out
yeah that was just an elaborate stunt
tied to a paid sponsorship Ariana was
spotted out in La after recording an
upcoming episode of the caller daddy
podcast where she deflected the question
how do you feel about moving I'm just
organizing some things tomorrow part one
of their explosive Bravo reunion finally
airs and despite Tom being photographed
out to dinner with influencer Carly Hale
a source tells E.T they are quote not
dating he's been focusing on what his
new future will look like meanwhile it
remains to be seen of selling Sunset
star krishelle stauss's legally married
to Australian singer G flip as E.T
reported there are no marriage records
on file I get protective over certain
aspects of our relationship but I
understand there's a lot of questions
around it I completely understand that
when our Bryce Sanders sat down with
chrisel last week she was vague about
when it even took place so is in Vegas
it was yeah how long ago was it it was a
little bit ago okay despite all of that
g-flip says they got matching tattoos of
their wedding vows this means she's the
one she is the one
now to a reality marriage imploding the
gloves are off and the ongoing divorce
of Real Housewives of Atlanta Star Kim
Zolciak and Kroy Biermann way to go
sweetness six days after Kim filed
papers demanding Croy be drug tested ET
has obtained new docs filed by the
former NFL star requesting Kim undergo a
psychological evaluation for underlying
mental issues including narcissistic
personality disorder I definitely to be
honest with you always I always want to
be famous Biermann alleges Kim is also a
compulsive Gambler which became so
consuming that quote she is unable to
properly care for the children and they
are now left financially devastated why
does this noise Make Mount heartbeat so
fast Kim's rep tells E.T they have no
comment at this time interestingly the
mom of six is still wearing her wedding
ring on Instagram Red Solo Cup
please